star wars nothing but star wars nothing
but Star Wars done huh
I saw the Star Wars Episode seven Cassy
initial cast you know like the main
people they like they want you to know
we're in the movie they have been
revealed the internet is blowing up with
two things one people reacting to the
information in two people requesting I
do a video on my reaction to the
information and will do that as the
voice of reason here to tell you how it
actually is first of all one thing you
should know is I like the cast list
they're fine actors they're a lot of
unknown or at least less knows the chick
in this movie is really unknown but I
like the fact they don't have huge
people Max von Sydow is probably the
biggest name in the movie because he
played the devil and needful things and
I think that's cool I know a lot of
people are excited about this did be in
the movie but the one for me that I'm
like that's awesome is John boyega hands
down I want to see what that dudes made
it was attacked the block he was like
one of the breakout performances of that
year he's very stoic and attacked the
block he has that leadership or Saanen
I'm like I could see him as a Jedi
breaking ground in Star Wars because
he's a British guy who might just be a
good guy then again Alec Guinness but
everyone knows obi-wan Kenobi was a spy
trained in the force by the Emperor and
then sent to find Luke and trained him
in the force of the Emperor can seduce
Luke obi-wan Kenobi was a Sith Lord the
clues are there pay attention Andy
Serkis is in the movie who are we
kidding he's going to be CGI something
ready The Dude's an actor he's played
live-action people before so he could be
a live-action guy but him being the king
of motion capture I feel like he's gonna
be something motion captured yes a Star
Wars movie still allowed to have CGI
don't freak out about that as long as
he's not almost like a lot of boobs I
think we'll be fine
however I'm not gonna get on camera be
like this movie's gonna be awesome
because of the cast list they're all
fine actors but that doesn't tell me the
movies gonna be great I have faith in
the movie because JJ Abrams is directing
it and a dude who wrote Empire Strikes
Back wrote it that to me makes me go
just probably it's looking good but the
initial cast list doesn't make me go oh
it's gonna feel so much like the
original trilogy we're back on track
first of all I feel kind of bad cuz i
feel like everyone feels like a kid on
Christmas like yes okay and I feel like
I'm the parent you know like the mom
going okay kids line up in an orderly
fashion calm down eat your breakfast and
we will open gifts sequentially with
each one from oldest to youngest and I'm
sapping the fun out of it but cast lists
just don't really do it for me because
you know what also had a pretty good cat
the prequels did I mean seriously the
initial main cast list yeah it's pretty
legit or let's flashback for a second
we're in the 90s the cash list for the
Phantom Menace has been revealed let's
say YouTube was around and I was doing
videos then no my video would have been
like something like all right holy
the cast list for the Phantom Menace has
been revealed and this movie is looking
better by the second first of all they
have Liam Neeson Oscar Schindler himself
playing a Jedi he's the one I guess
who's training obi-wan I think or Yoda
is but he's the one training obi-wan so
he's an Obi Wan's master that's right
obi-wan Kenobi was trained by Academy
award-nominated
Oscar Schindler he wouldn't McGregor
from trained spottings in the movie he
plays young obi-wan Kenobi young obi-wan
Kenobi trained by Schindler they're
gonna kick ass that chick in the
professional plays Luke and Leia's mom
which is badass she was a good actress
in there she had kind of that tough vibe
to her I feel like she's gonna be this
good leader in this movie like someone
who can actually form a rebellion they
even have the original Emperor Palpatine
playing him younger samuel l.jackson in
the movie to samuel l holy samuel
l.jackson is like Billy Dee Williams
with 90s edge so imagine everything
Lando was in the original trilogy but
it's Jules Winnfield from pulp fiction
yeah as a Jedi this movie is going to be
the movie of the century the cast list
is great I'm really pumped I am excited
they have good actors that have George
Lucas back at the helm Anthony Daniels
and Kenny Baker are reprising their
roles of c-3po and r2d2 I'm telling you
I've been waiting for this movie for all
my life so I'm just I'm pumped they're
doing it right and yeah that would have
been it and that's why cast lists really
don't make me think the movie is
destined to be great and a lot of people
are freaking out like all the movies
gonna feel so old-school proof positive
because Kenny Baker Anthony Daniels and
Peter Mayhew are reprising their roles
of c-3po r2d2 and Chewbacca that doesn't
really do it for me
because if the implication is that the
movies going to be good because it's
going to feel old school because those
three guys are reprising their roles
from the original trilogy and the
implication is also that the prequels
were going to be good and they were
going to feel old school because those
three people reprise their roles in the
prequels also and what were the prequels
not stay with me now it's a yes that's
right they were not good nor did they
feel like the original trilogy so
apparently having those three reprised
their roles from the original trilogy
actually make a Star Wars movie feel
like the original trilogy created I
think it's cool that those guys are cast
as their original roles as novelty but
if you just had random short guy number
one playing r2d2 in random tell guy
number two playing Chewbacca I wouldn't
know that it's not Peter Mayhew and
Kenny Baker see what I mean a voice a
reason I feel like I'm sapping the fund
I just want to be a realist about it
granted I feel like the movie is going
to be good I have faith in the director
I have faith in the writers the crew
looks like they know what they're
talking about their Star Wars fans as
movies probably going to be awesome and
I feel like the actor is gonna do a fine
job in it because they're good actors
and they have a good director I feel
like I keep casting at arm's distance
now because I was there for the 90s for
the Phantom Menace cashing reveal and
ever since then I'm like okay give me
more what's the movie about really who
are these people playing that's more
interesting to me the really absurd
about the casting was the people calling
sexism and racism because there's one
black guy in one check among like a
larger cast of white dudes it was weird
to me cuz I'm like out the gate the
movies racist and sexist based on one
main casting reveal when there's more
casting to come and the movie doesn't
have just nine people and if there are
more people in the movie there's a rumor
that John boyega might be the main guys
it's still racist if he is and
supposedly there's information that
there's still another character to be
cast and they want a mixed-race female
in her 20s to play it that's like to
quotas right there it is the movie still
sexist and racist is the implication
here that in order for a movie to not be
racist or sexist you have to cast it
based on a certain quota of race and sex
because that in and of itself is racist
and sexist people see sexism and racism
where they want to see sexism and racism
as long as the movie is well executed
and a good Star Wars movie I feel like
that's what'll matter so in the end I do
like the casting in this movie but when
I saw everyone freaking out online be
like it's gonna be so old-school in
awesome because of this at least had to
address the fact what it's like not
necessarily but they do have qualified
and good actors in this movie some of
the original cast is coming back and
supposed us worth touching on but I
already knew they were coming back so I
felt like I didn't have to touch on it
but casting is step one now I am pumped
to hear about what the movies about what
planets it takes place on who the
characters are what they're doing and
that's badass John boyega is the one I
got my eye on I'm like I feel like
you're the guy John boyega your agent
needs a raise seriously jumping like I'm
gonna be in this little
he attacked the block and I'm going to
be in Star Wars yeah your agent a fruit
basket because he does deserve it so the
Star Wars casting what do you think
about it I'll put a link below to an
article that has the casting since I
didn't talk about it much I just talked
about my perspective on casting in
general and that's just kind of what I
do on my videos talk about what I think
so what everything about the cast in
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more and I wouldn't want this video
to be racist or sexist so I'm gonna
blatantly have John boyega and the white
chick be on the thumbnail yeah and that
is how stupid and absurd that is
exactly how it sounds now
[Music]